l'hiver je le disais deux nouvelles
fosses communes auraient donc été
découverte près de marioupol selon le
maire de la ville c'est là que sont
enterrés gulliver les civils tués dans
la ville un
oui ces images réalité ne font que
confirmer ce que le maire de la ville
disait depuis plusieurs jours et puis ce
que l'on savait déjà des témoignages des
gens qui ont réussi à sortir de
marioupol qui parlait des corps qui sont
entassés dans les rues de la difficulté
d'emmener les corps vers les cimetières
en fait au tout début de l'encerclement
de marioupol et de l'attaqué des forces
russes sur la ville on savait qu'il
était très difficile d'amener les corps
au cimetière quand ils sont morts dans
les bombardements
là avec ces images satellites le cren
multiplient à nouveau les accusations de
crimes de guerre contre la russie et il
semble évidente que il y a des milliers
de morts dans cette ville de marioupol
qui contient demi million d'habitants
avant la guerre après on peut se
demander exactement comment ils sont
morts et de quel genre de crimes de
guerre il s'agit cibler les zones
civiles et déjà un crime de guerre sauf
si on peut dire qu'il y avait des cibles
militaires à l'endroit mais vu que 95%
des bâtiments à marioupol ont été
endommagés je pense qu'il serait
difficile pour la russie et d'argumenter
qu'elle cibler uniquement les cibles
militaires et puis il y a le fait qu'on
sait de par le fait que si peu d'autobus
d'évacuation ont pu sortir de marioupol
que les forces russes empêcher les
civils de sortir de la ville de s'enfuir
donc de cette possibilité de mourir sous
les bombes après on n'a pas encore
d'évidence vraiment un marioupol
assassinats de civils comme cela a pu
être documenté à bout de chats et autres
endroits de la région de kiev après la
libération de ces localités on ne sait
pas comment ces gens dans ces fosses
communes sont morts et on ne sait pas
évidemment exactement combien ils sont
de gulliver vous l'avez